hello everyone I don't know if you
remember a couple of days ago I told you
about that fiasco in the Croatian news
so I gave another interview for another
news portal one from my hometown that
doesn't deal in witchcraft and click
baiting so I will put a link to it in
the description below you can check it
out if you're interested it might be
kind of a nice follow up on the Q&A and
it's not in English but I'm sure the
auto-translate will do a nice job so
that being said here we have another
game from the 1959 candidates tournament
Paul Karis versus Michael Tao and
probably all of you already know this
tal won the tournament Karis was second
in the tournament so two of them were
really it was really a race till the end
of the tournament so one thing that's
really exciting about this game is that
Karis actually plays like Tao in this
game but you'll see what I mean by this
and another thing I couldn't find a
photo of the two of them playing which
is quite weird as I mean two of them
were one of them was gonna win the
candidates and I don't know I know the
film was expensive but you kinda have to
take a photo of towel playing against
Carris or maybe I'm just an unable to
find a photo but I did find a nice photo
of the two of them playing and it's like
in extremely high quality this is not
from the 1959 candidates but it was
played a bit earlier in in the spring of
1959 in Tallinn Estonia it's the match
Estonia vs. Latvia and here you have
Karis also with white pieces playing
against Thailand you can see the
audience there in the background so a
beautiful photo if I do say so myself so
we'll look at it after the game one one
more time but now let's see the game
caris opens with a forehand and we have
c5 by tall Knight to f3 d6 d4 see
characters Knight captures and now a six
the con variation Bishop to d3 Knight to
c6 carries captures Knight captures we
have D captures on c6 and Karis castles
and here tile immediately pushes a 5 now
which is a good decision you don't want
your point to be a locking about your
light square bishop now tile is free to
develop
both of his bishops and this e 5 phone
is now having in that light square
bishop of Karis on v3 so nice the D 2 we
have Queen to c7 and now we have a 4
with some ideas of maybe blocking the
Queen side would move like a five and we
have Knight to f6 and here Queen to f3
and Queen to f3 might be might be a
weird-looking move you know why why
don't you leave that f3 square for the
knight but Harris has a different idea
he wants to go Knight to c4 and then
maybe even push a5 and go night to b6 or
if he wants to he will also be able to
go to c4 and then maybe to e3 and to f5
so a lot of a lot of options for this
Knight Bishop to c5 bite all night the
c-4 now and dalla castles we have
Knights - III although a5 was still a
possibility and this after carrots would
decide to play Bishop to g5 this Bishop
would probably have to retreat the e7
and then maybe carrots could jam this
night to be six but here Karis plays
Knight to e3 as now he kind of prefers
this f5 square so rook to e8 and now
Bishop to c4 Bishop to e6 tile
immediately wants to exchange that
powerful bishop
so Bishop captures rook captures and now
Knight to a5 and this is a wonderful
square for the knight so tell it that it
definitely doesn't want to leave it
there he he kicks it away g6 we have
night to h6 this comes with check came
to g7 and now rook to d1 rocked d8 by
Tali immediately challenging Harris's
work on the Open File Road captures
Queen captures and now this is kind of
the critical moment of the game so far
Karis
pretty much played everything correctly
now Karis wants to play I mean he should
play g4 and g5
trying to kick away this knight on f6
and to pressure this week f7 pawn but
here Karis makes a slight mistake that
will in D and B probably the thing that
will cost him the game he plays Bishop
to g5
and here tall place the only move that
takes advantage of this Bishop to g5
move
he plays Queen to d4 so unpinning as the
the knight was pinned here as the Queen
was on b8 also he's attacking the b2
phone he's pressuring the a4 pawn and
there is a double attack on the e4 pawn
so quite a powerful move that Harris
missed the problem is you can never grab
the e4 pawn to e4 pawn is protected by
tactics but I will get back to that the
problem is you can to defend the beat of
born because of atactic Queen captures
an f2 check Queen captures Bishop
capture screen captures and now Knight
captures Ani for checking the King for
King the bishop here on g5 King moves
and then you simply grab the bishop and
you're down two points as white black is
winning this game easily so after this
Queen to d4 move Karis played h4 so now
the same idea doesn't apply because the
bishop n g5 is protected and like I said
you can never grab the e4 pawn as it's
protected by tactics if you grab it then
of course simply removing the defender
of the queen with check and after the
bishop is captured then Queen captures
Queen and you lose the game
another thing even if you don't capture
with the Queen even if you capture with
the night this doesn't work because
you're getting checkmated Queen captures
f7 King h8 Queen - GA - checkmate
but after this h4 move of course now tal
will grab the B to bond so Queen
captures on b2
we have rook to d1 and now we have
Bishop to d4 not allowing caris to
activate via rook to d7 because chaos
was actually threatening rook to d7
check and you can't capture with the
night because because of the same same
checkmate Queen captures f7 Queen g8 of
course capturing the night first so
Bishop to d4 not allowing the rook to
enter the game and now comes rope to d3
here caris is still down upon and now
again he's threatening the c3 move now
that the rook and the Queen are guarding
the c3 square and here tall again goes
for the only good move Queen captures
and C
sometimes the only good move is the one
you actually first consider but not
always and here this was another idea
kara said if tall plays Queen captures
on c2 then carries goes rogue captors
and e4 and this was played in the game
each character some before and now II
five a very interesting idea of course
if you move the night you're getting
checkmated if you play rook captures
then you get Queen captures on f6 check
and you're getting checkmate it just
just the same
so after this this if I've moved towel
plays the only move that really kills a
whites attack and Indian it's probably
this move that Karis missed and that
that will win tart all the game so a
very interesting position so feel free
to pause the video and try to find tiles
move
it's a very nice move and also you'll
probably realize it since its kind of
the title of this video but nevertheless
see if you found that you're an
excellent player as always and for those
of you just want to enjoy the show here
came to f8 my towel and this pretty much
stops Karis attack completely I have to
capture with the pawn if you capture the
night with the bishop you have to
capture it you don't want to be down
upon peace now Queen to c1 check King
moves and Queen captures night on h6 and
now the attack is over and black is
simply winning
so after this King to f8 move by tal he
captures on f6 was played and now Queen
to c3 now Harris will still try to
attack but tal knows that if the Queen's
get off the board that the endgame is
winning for him due to the test see porn
if the Queen's are exchanged
so Queen to g4 avoiding the exchange now
Queen to e1 check King h2 and now Queen
captures on f2 grabbing another pawn
queen to h3 and now comes Queen to be
won again Queen to b3 and now b5 not
allowing but the White Queen to capture
the b7 pawn captures captures and here
Queen to a3 again before
notice that all the phones are protected
so Harris doesn't really have a chance
to pick up pick up
any of them Queen to b3 and now Queen to
e5 check King h1 Queen to e1 check King
King to h1 and again Queen to e5 check
towel repeats the position a couple of
times to first probably to try and find
a better move came 2 H 1 and now again
you can't repeat the position three
times but now Queen to d6 again keeping
keeping an eye on all the pawns
everything is everything is good in
blacks camp and now older elders left is
to push the past pawn so came to g1 we
have d3 Queen to d1 blocking the past
pawn but now Queen to c5 check King
moves and Queen to c2 again threatening
to exchange Queens Queen to f3 and now
d2 notice that Queen Queen to a it
doesn't really give white anything black
will simply block it with the rook so we
have Bishop captures Queen captures and
there's really nothing to do here
so in this position poor Karis resigned
at the game so a very nice a very nice
attacking game by poor Karis even though
he he he missed that Bishop to g5 idea
and you know towel after that hard to
say is it really a mistake or is it like
a bigger inaccuracy but after that I'll
only play the strongest moves and after
that King to f8 a monstrosity Karis was
really done for but it's interesting I
will show it one more time the final
standings of this tournament as you can
see thought with first place with 20
points out of 27 28 carries with 18 and
a half out of 28 Karis actually defeated
tall in this tournament with three wins
to 1 this is the only game towel won
against Carris in the 1959 candidates
and still you can see that tall Indian
prevailed because tall was more
successful against the other players
like for example crushing Fischer 4 to 0
and a couple of other players shared
that exact same fate so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it here we
can we can marvel at this beautiful
photo
more time before we end the video I
would like to thank John Anthony tables
for a contribution to my channel think a
lot I'm really glad you're still
enjoying the content as usual you can
check to my previous videos here I think
all for watching and I will see you soon
and like I said feel free to check out
the article or with a link in the
description below
thank you all I will see you soon